avavocate civiliste.
C'C'est pour la chanson très
coconnue "Shape of You"
ququ'Ed Sheeran est poursuivi.
QuQu'est-ce qu'on lui reprococh?
- - Vous avez raison, c'est un
susuccès planétaire, un record e
vevente.
CeCe qu'on peut te comprendre,
c'c'est qu'elle chemine il répèe
ququatre notes deux fois, il
dit... il a deux compositeurs
ququi le poursuivent en disant,l
nonous octroyait, deux ans
auauparavant, en 10 les mêmes
paparoles, alors on est plagié,l
y y a un procès de trois semains
popour des notes répétées.
- - Ça se passe en Angleterre, e
prprésume que les règles en ce i
coconcerne les plages, doivent e
rarassembler.
CoComment peut conclure qu'il
s's'agit de plagiat.
- - Il faut prouver, c'est la
pepersonne qui dit qui a été
cocopiée, doit prouver qu'elle a
étété copiée.
SiSix mois plus tard Lady Gaga
didits quelque chose qui
reressemble, on est dans la
cocoïncidence musicale.
EnEnsuite il faut prouver que
c'c'est assez original, ce ne sa
papas la gamme de dos par exemp,
mamais ce qui est copié dans les
dedeux, à une similitude
imimportante.
C'C'est souvent ça le débat.
- - Je présume qu'elle chemine e
dédéfend, qu'est-ce qu'il dit?
- - Je reviens au tweet, il dite
n'n'ai jamais entendu cette
chchanson et avant d'être
popoursuivi.
SiSi j'avais voulu emprunter un
exextrait, je l'ai déjà fait por
d'd'autres chansons, j'aurais
donné le crédit auteur.
EnEn plus, honnêtement, c'est
ququatre notes et, sont assez
cocommunes, et c'est assez
inintéressant, la semaine
dedernière, il a chanté en pleie
cocours c'était amusant.
IlIl a chanté une chanteuse
amaméricaine.
IlIl a vraiment beaucoup de
chchansons qui reprennent ces
mmêmes notes.
- - On a vu d'autres cas
rérécemment, celui de Katy Perry
ququi est réglée depuis longtem.
- - Ça s'est réglé la semaine
dedernièère.
OnOn avait pour une chanson très
popopulaire, et convient de lui
dodonner raison.
IlIl n'y avait pas de plagiat.
- - Ça s'est réglé, ici au Québ,
esest-ce qu'on en a des cas de
plplagiat, tout le monde pense..
jeje vous suggère que tout le
momonde pense à Claude Robinson,
mamais aussi pour des artistes e
cocompositeurs.
InInterprète.
- - À Chantal de Paris pour sa
chchanson et, dans un album très
coconnu, de chansons commençaiet
papar un appel téléphonique, ete
paparler de sortie des filles,
mamais le juge à comparer, il
avavait décidé qu'il n'y avait s
dede plagiat, c'est intéressant,
c'c'est un plagiat de mots.
CÇa n'avait pas à voir avec la
mumusique.
LeLe juge dit, ce n'est pas
susuffisant pour décider il y au
plplagiat.
OnOn avait déjà poursuivivi au
QuQuébec et Céline Dion, Jacques
GoGoldman, pour la chanson prièe
papaïenne.
IlIl y a quelques poursuites au
QuQuébec en effet.
J'J'imagine qu'avec toutes les
plplates-formes d'écoute, tout t
acaccessible à tout le monde, on
dodoit assister à une hausse de
seses recours et?
- - Tout à fait, aux États-Unis,
jeje pourrais vous lire le bottn
dedes chanteurs populaires,
IsIsabelle, beaucoup de
popoursuites.
L'L'accès est plus facile avec s
plplates-formes, que ce soit
spspotify, j'aimais trahir mon
ââge, mais dans le temps
fafallait... je pense que
ququelqu'un te plagiait, mais oa
cocomme mission de le mettre en
cocontact.
- - Je vais te poursuivre enseme
auau tribunal en votre nom